hi I'm Todd Smith with the Roy Hill
companies in United States I'm going to
choose the question put forward by the
Duke how are you integrating technology
to enhance value create capital and
collaboration within your corporate
structure we're one of the largest
education and learning companies in the
world and increasingly digital
technology is enabling us to help
students and teachers get better scores
in education we have been working with
adaptive personal programs which are
very interactive we engaging very
exciting for students and for teachers
recently we put together a collaboration
without book to develop new I guess you
call them hyper books but they're really
digital platforms for high schools for
our course were in there and for higher
education we have wonderful products
like LearnSmart which play on
metacognitive processes to engage bring
engage students in what you need to know
I'm referring back to lectures the
further back to text using a lot of game
theory to just improve the interest
level in the subject matter this is very
exciting
and so it's a marriage of Education or
curriculum expertise which we've had for
years with new technology and new ways
are presenting the subject matter more
interactively and more in more modern
way with students of all ages with
teachers and so you can be anywhere in
the world you won't be restricted by
bricks and mortar
you could be in India or China Indonesia
or you could be out in the plains of the
United States and be able to avail of
this extraordinary learning experience
with the best teachers and the best
programs so we're very excited about the
potential for this program working with
a lot of different companies a lot of
bringing people in our own company
we're advancing this so we look forward
to telling you more about this
makes me